bienvenido a esta cultura desde casa una
cita que hoy arranca con el kazajo más
famoso de la ficción
borat y es que por un lado sacha baron
cohen vuelve a pegarse el bigote en una
subsiguiente película ya no para
evidenciar nuestros prejuicios sino el
auge del autoritarismo esto es hoy desde
eeuu disfrazado en donald trump en un
mitin y queriendo regalar a su hija al
vice presidente mike pence
al frío
si bien el actor en detalle los de
chicago se ven ya como la activista a
big man también nos lleva hasta un eeuu
que se supone de los 60 pero que va y
viene en el tiempo para decir el país
está mostrando su peor versión puede
hacer mejor
en concreto resolviendo de una vez por
todas sus vergüenzas como en interpreta
una de ellas como uno de los enjuiciados
por las protestas en torno a la
convención demócrata de 68 pero quien
transmite esto en la cinta quien evoca
racismo corrupción y derechos vulnerados
de ayer y de hoy es el director
aaron sorkin y de forma totalmente
intencional de forma totalmente
inteligente
el elenco aborda su acusación que es
política el escenario juega bien el
paralelismo 60 2020 pero los dilemas que
se plantean son lo mejor con una
izquierda pro elecciones y otra cansada
de no enfrentarse al rol de cohen que
llegó a conocer a hoffman le interrogan
cuál es el precio de la revolución su
vida responde este
d
[Aplausos]
a través de él
es este
[Aplausos]
i
en otros temas méxico y austria han
vuelto a abrir la caja de pandora del
arte que no es sino la devolución de
patrimonio histórico expoliado o
considerado propio por un país está
tocado azteca de 2 metros de ancho y 222
plumas sobre oro con incrustaciones
centra la riña en el marco del
bicentenario de independencia de mexico
el presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador quiere exhibir para 2021 sus
tesoros y a esa misión que llama
imposible mando por europa la primera
dama con ahínco en la pieza reconocida
como penacho de moctezuma más allá de lo
que decida de nuevo el ministerio de
cultura austriaco es interesante la
postura del bell museum de viena que es
que la custodia insiste primero en la
historia que la corona que no se sabe
cómo llegó a austria tal vez como
obsequio de moctezuma a cortes no fue
del emperador lo segundo en que insiste
es en su fragilidad no es que rechaza en
un préstamo sino que trasladarla
pieza prehispánica podría destruir la
montes
sabemos bien que no era el penacho de
moctezuma era el de un sacerdote sabemos
por los códices que el propio moctezuma
nunca llegó un penacho como éste y esta
controversia es antigua
tenemos que ir atrás en la historia
reciente de 2010 a 2012 tuvimos un
proyecto científico una colaboración
entre restauradores del museo y
restauradores de mexico y el resultado
fue que estaba bastante claro que en el
transporte del penacho se correría alto
riesgo de dañarlo son plumas de 600 años
de antigüedad en una condición muy
frágil y transportarlo de cualquier
manera sería un gran peligro para el
objeto estar colocado en ese sitio que
se identifica como que es el repositorio
de la raíz directa de la nacionalidad
mexicana que serían las civilizaciones
prehispánicas pues ha hecho que el
objeto nunca pierda esta connotación de
símbolo nacional que es importante
recuperar es ingenuo obviar que la
cultura también es política cuando
montezuma en el siglo xxi 6 como ahora
varios creen que con ello obrador se
erige entre el pueblo mexicano
qué es un expolio y que lo del traslado
es una excusa de austria sea como fuere
nos lleva hasta turquía donde los
teatros independientes y los asociados
con la oposición denuncian que el
gobierno de recep tayyip erdogán los
está excluyendo de los fondos de rescate
de ayuda por cómic 19 esta es la
acusación que emiten algunos como
fumaban hachís 50 con dificultades para
representar sus producciones y al borde
del cierre mientras que hace poco el
teatro ya nani aquejó censura porque el
gobierno le canceló una versión en kurdo
de trompetas y frambuesas del nobel
italiano darío fo cuando en turco no
había dado problemas de orden público
como dicen las autoridades
entre los teatros que recibieron ayudas
había unos que se habían instalado sólo
dos semanas antes de la fecha de
solicitud de los fondos hay compañías
que ni tienen nombre teatral como
constructoras quizás tengan teatros pero
es cuestionable tampoco sabemos quién
decidió asignar los apoyos y ahora han
agregado nuevas reglas de acceso a las
ayudas no se puede tener una
deuda tributaria pero muy pocos no la
tienen
y la guinda la pone ana tijoux a un año
del inicio de las protestas en chile y a
punto del plebiscito sobre una nueva
constitución el tema que oirán es un
tributo a su combativo pueblo que tal y
como canta la dignidad lo constituye
frente a la injusticia la violencia y la
persecución la rapera menor de 14 años
en similar hay la acompaña con preciosos
versos en mapuche cuídense y muchas
gracias que el mundo entero sepa
y dispararon sin tregua
por la paz ellos dijeron
torturando nuestro pueblo
[Música]
américa nos une
octubre
sustituye